the big story today an Alabama Democrat
is heading to the US Senate for the
first time in more than two decades Doug
Jones upset Republican Roy Moore last
night by about 20,000 votes this will
give the GOP only a two seat majority in
the Senate when Jones arrives next month
the more campaign was hit hard when nine
women accused him of sexual misconduct
decades ago he fiercely denied the
claims Moore has refused to concede
those saying there may be a recount at
his victory party last night John said
the outcome shows Alabama's dignity and
respect for others in this state
regardless of which zip code you live in
is gonna get a fair shake in LA this
morning President Trump tweeted I said
Roy Moore will not be able to win the
general election I was right major
Garrett is at the White House with the
impact of this race on the president
major good morning good morning our
irrepressible president proclaims even
in defeat that he was right all along
and some of his supporters may in fact
believe it but the simple truth is the
president is now a two-time loser in
Alabama
one of the most Pro Trump states in the
country remember the president backed
appointed senator Luther Strange in the
Republican primary strange lost more now
more has lost and the President's agenda
outside of tax cuts is deeply damaged
the president campaigned for more just
last Friday while in Pensacola Florida
driving his appeal deep into southern
Alabama me medium markets to drive up
Moore's
turnout it didn't work GOP turnout
declined while Democratic turnout surged
defying the president and his former
chief strategist Steve Benin who backed
more against the GOP establishment and
in theory on behalf of the president's
agenda this morning on his radio show
Bannon credited the Democratic Party for
driving up the doug jones turnout now
several Republicans told us that Moore's
defeat will galvanize Republicans on tax
reform Republicans knowing that they've
got to act quickly before they lose one
vote in the Senate the president will
lunch with tea with Keith
tax negotiators here at the White House
today and one other verdict has been
rendered on this Alabama election one
top trump adviser told me this White
House has the worst political operation
in two generations Republican or
Democrat Yale all right major you put it
in perspective as always thank you very
much